bonjour bienvenue à tous dans europe
hebdo c'est parti pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne une actualité
dominée par les régionales en france les
régionales qui ont vu le front national
devenir une nouvelle fois le premier
parti de france
c'est un peu long de choc dans toute
l'europe face à ces résultats
mais nous verrons que ce n'est pas la
première fois et que d'autres pays
européens sont concernés à l'heure avant
d'en débattre avec mes invité l'europe à
droite tout c'est la question de la
semaine
lundi 7 décembre toute la presse
européenne se réveille avec la gueule de
bois
marée noire le pen prend la france
triomphe de l'extrême droite fn premier
parti de france à l'instar de la presse
française les principaux journaux
européens constatent avec amertume
l'inexorable ascension de marine le pen
et s'interroge sur les blocages de ce
pays piliers de la construction
européenne terrorisme insécurité chômage
peur de l'étranger déception chronique
vis-à-vis des politiques de tous bords
les mots français sont nombreux et germe
dans les urnes
une réalité qui n'est pas seulement
hexagonale mais européenne autriche
pologne angleterre suède la vague
xénophobe touche la plupart des pays de
l'union
dans un message sur sa page facebook
matteo renzi premier ministre italien
met en garde l'europe l'europe doit
changer sans une vision stratégique
surtout en matière d'économie et de
croissance les forces populistes vont
gagner
si l'europe ne change pas son parcours
tout de suite les institutions
européennes risquent de devenir les
meilleurs alliés de marine le pen
une prédiction en forme d'ultimatum pour
l'europe et ses dirigeants
l'europe est elle en train de virer à
droite tout voire à l'extrême droite
c'est la question que je vais poser à
mes invités sylvie goulard bonjour un
joueur vous êtes députée européenne
membre du groupe libéral démocrate merci
d'être avec nous edouard martin vous
êtes député apparenté socialiste vous
n'avez toujours pas pris votre carton
mais je crois beaucoup en me pose la
question
bon et merci d'être avec nous en tout
cas et christian spillmann vous êtes
journaliste hala effet vous connaissez
très bien les arcanes de cette petite
société bruxelloise
sylvie boulanger d'avant le tourner vers
vous est ce que ça vous étonne ce
résultat du front national en france
non malheureusement je dirais qu'on s'y
attendait même si l'ampleur de la
victoire
dans certaines régions notamment est
très préoccupante va falloir voir
évidemment ce qui va se passer au second
tour je pense qu'il faut prendre ça très
au sérieux non seulement d'ailleurs pour
le front national mais pour ce que ça
signifie pour les partis modérés
donc ben là finalement ça signifie quoi
pour les partis modérés des gens votent
plus contre ouais les partis modérés qui
n'adhèrent en connaissance de cause aux
thèses de marine le pen ça m'arrive très
souvent d'entrer en discussions avec des
personnes qui disent vouloir voter ou
qui disent avoir voté pour le front
national
je suis absolument frappé par leur
méconnaissance totale et total de son
programme économique internationale
sortie de l'otan sortie luxe était enfin
ils veulent protester contre ceux qui
sont en place et pas seulement le
gouvernement socialiste mais toute la
classe politique modérée qu'il ya de
sérieuses questions à se poser dans
martin vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse est ce que c'est juste un vote
de contestation selon vous de mon point
de vue non j'aurais eu la même analyse
il ya quelques années en arrière
aujourd'hui je pense que malheureusement
les idées du front national sur bien
ancrée dans la tête même si je suis
d'accord avec sylvie goulard lorsqu'on
discute avec les électeurs du front
national on se rend compte de la
méconnaissance totale de ce qu'est
exactement le système le pen les
méconnaissances du programme de l'europe
était terrain mais justement marine le
pen joue là dessus sur cette
méconnaissance là et je crois que il
faut qu'on arrête de se cacher derrière
son petit doigt
moi j'ai vu dans ma région des villages
frontaliers que luxembourg des gens qui
travaillent au luxembourg
où ils ont des villas que jamais on
pourra se payer nous des classes
moyennes supérieures qui vient pas seul
immigré
mais le front national fait des 70 80 %
et il a peur de leurs de l'immigré il
faut oser dire le mot a peur du musulman
la peur de l'islam il faut maintenant
arrêter de se cacher derrière son petit
doigt
il ya effectivement des effets
économiques le chômage la peur des
réfugiés la crise les attentats ça je
suis d'accord mais en réalité lorsqu'on
discute avec avec du temps avec les
électeurs du front national à un moment
donné lorsque vous démonter leur
programme tous arrivent sur l'économie
et le social il y arrive toujours un
moment où ils finissent par vous dire
oui mais moi je ne veux pas d'islam en
france ouais de toute façon c'est
quelque chose qu'on voit de manière
globale au niveau européen un christian
cette espèce de peur du musulman
cette identité un petit peu attaqué
marche
moi ce que je vois surtout ce qui est
très inquiétant c'est une montée de
formation elles sont pas simplement à
l'extrême droite qui ont un discours
anti européen l'europe est toujours
absente mais ces gens là ne veulent pas
de l'europe
il a critiqué la comtesse qu'ils veulent
la tuer et à madame le pen a dit
clairement mais je ne vois vraiment pas
pourquoi la commission pour moi ça doit
disparaître c'est ça qui est inquiétant
après qu'on soit surpris par la montée
de l'extrême droite en france mais on
lui a préparé le lit on l'a invité
on a joué avec l'extrême droite qui n'en
a fait un adversaire la gauche en a fait
un adversaire pour casser la droite la
droite on a fait un espèce de pouvant
taille pour eux pour la goutte
tout le monde a joué avec ça qu'on a
fait du politicien et aujourd'hui on
s'étonne que le front national soit
ancré dans la plupart des régions
françaises avec des votes les scores
énorme
moi ce qui m'étonne mais si je puis me
permettre sur la question de l'islam et
je rejoins tout à fait ce qu'a dit
monsieur martin sur probablement la
question identitaire qui est au centre
d'une grande partie du vote front
national au delà la protestation vous
avez raison il ya quand même une chose
qu'il faut sortir un peu de leur
programme et ce qui se passe aux etats
unis quand vous voyez les propos de
donald trump qui sont des propos mais
anti islam dans un pays
ou l'arrière-plan est tout à fait
différent dans le rapport aux religions
ou normalement la liberté religieuse est
quelque chose de véritablement de
protégé par la constitution américaine
bien au delà et dans l'esprit des gens
bon je crois que le déferlement du
radicalisme islamique ce que produit des
shows que produit le wahhabisme de
l'arabie saoudite etc est en train de
poser un problème au monde entier en
europe bien sûr ça crée des conséquences
particulières mais ça n'est pas un
phénomène qui est proprement européen
mais là moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
finalement on voit bien que les partis
classiques de gouvernement n'offre plus
d'alternative en fait à cette crise à
cette crise identitaire à cette crise
économique à cette crise sociale est-ce
que c'est d'une part parce qu'ils sont à
côté de la plaque
ou est-ce que ils ont juste mis en place
un système qui permet de taper ou d'une
part sur les abstentionnistes et ceux
qui votent fn et de fêtes n'offrent pas
de solution edouard martin était depuis
de trop nombreuses années les partis
politiques classiques qui gouverne à
tour de rôle mène une politique entre
guillemets dites raisonnables il faut
rester il faut être raisonnable on ne
peut pas dépenser ce qu'on n'a pas le
pacte de stabilité j'en passe et des
meilleurs effectivement je ne dis pas
qu'il faille jeté l'argent par la
fenêtre
mais tout ça dans un contexte économique
dramatique 25 millions de chômeurs en
europe
alors on vient de déclarer un état
d'urgence en france l'europe dit
effectivement il faut maintenant se
protéger il faut se doter de moyens y
compris financier pour mieux armer la
police plus de policiers plus d'armée et
c'est là on compte pas les deniers mais
en nous sommes en situation de guerre
économique
il aurait fallu un plan marshall pour
lutter contre le chômage contre la
précarité et terrain et que fait que
font parce que là aussi c'est pas la
faute de l'europe en tant que
institution que font les états ils font
semblant de ne rien voir et donc cette
politique en tout cas perçue comme telle
de du lala petit des copains et des
coquins je te file map l'acheteur film
est une marque donnera tout ça pour
faire le soin d'y être casse émergents
espèce de casse c'est l'autre soins et
bien on arrive à de tels résultats
christian spillmann à l'époque de
du 21 avril 2002 on avait poussé des
cris d'orfraie dans toute l'europe
jean marie le pen au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle les
organiseurs en autriche on avait poussé
aussi décrit leur frein on a
l'impression aujourd'hui que c'est un
peu passé que finalement c'est quelque
chose d'un peu logique on n'a pas vu
véritablement remis dans la presse
européenne et avec matteo renzi des
dirigeants ce lancer contre marine le
pen ou tout du moins ce que ça peut
représenter est-ce que l'europe a
capitulé sur cette question l'extrême
droite vous rappeler le jeu de chirac à
l'époque qui avait essayé d'appeler à ce
qu'on ne fasse pas la grande coalition
en autriche et qui s'était fait taper
sur les doigts en disant qu'est ce que
c'est que cette ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures d'un état souverain
donc effectivement les les états membres
sont un petit peu réticent mais ils ont
tous le même problème finalement d'une
manière ou d'une autre à gérer il se
demande comment on peut faire et quelle
réponse on peut apporter condamné qu'est
ce que vous voulez condamné condamné un
système politique qui a amené
l'émergence de ce parti et qui a amené
marine le pen à être la prétendante au
deuxième tour en se demandant qui va
s'effacer de la droite ou de la gauche
pour les laisser la seconde place ils
savent tous qu'ils ont ça nous on est
encore dans un système où on a une
droite une gauche qui s'affrontent la
plupart ils sont en coalition déjà mal
si la solution ça sera pas là la grande
coalition
c'est encore une fois on voit bien qu'il
ya des tas de niveaux auxquels on peut
agir pour ma part d'abord je crois que
par rapport à ce qu'a dit monsieur
martin tout à l'heure il est quand même
important de répéter que la xénophobie
la préférence nationale c'est contraire
à la constitution c'est contraire aux
valeurs européennes ont prêché sera
peut-être un peu dans le désert mais si
on fait plus du tout c'est plus grave
donc personnellement
et d'ailleurs si vous regardez par
exemple j'ai beaucoup regardé la presse
allemande depuis lundi c'est un choc et
les allemands sont particulièrement
préoccupés par ce qui se passe en france
et je crois qu'il faut faire rentrer
cela dans le débat français parce que
ces élections en france on a fait croire
que c'est des élections régionales
en fait ça a été la primaire de la
primaire la plupart des candidats on n'a
pas parlé les compétences des régions
d'accord c'était très facile de faire
quelque chose qui ne soit pas du
copinage
parce qu'une grande coalition en
allemagne c'est quoi c'est un contrat
c'est pas la droite et la gauche vont
ensemble au lit
embrassons nous folleville c'est pas ça
ces voix là il ya les transports
compétences de la région ont fait un
accord sur un plan transport qui peut
être porté par des gens dans ma jeune
d'origine horizon paru négociation clair
strict exactement c'est pas du copinage
notamment il ya des moyens de faire des
coalitions sur des programmes et je vais
vous dire une chose quand on va sur le
terrain
si ce que les gens demandent ils en ont
marre que les élus ne travaillent pas ce
qu'ils voudraient c'est que leurs élus
travaillent c'est qu'ils disent l'emploi
des jeunes ça a été dit on est dans une
situation d'urgence
terrible dans le pays vous avez beaucoup
de régions dans lesquelles les jeunes ne
sont pas formés ils sortent de l'école
sans formation il se trouve que les
régions ont la compétence de la
formation professionnelle il n'y a pas
une formation professionnelle de droit
qui formation professionnelle de gauche
et les formations qui donne des boulots
ou des formations qui vous laisse à la
maison donc là aussi on avait la
possibilité de travailler selon vous en
fait on n'a pas assez fait c'est quoi le
permet je crois que les médias n'aiment
pas beaucoup n'aide pas beaucoup je vais
vous dire pourquoi parce que j'ai
observé que plusieurs articles par
exemple sur des candidats à la
présidence d'une région et est centrée
uniquement sur leur positionnement par
rapport à la primaire éventuels qui
pourraient avoir lieu dans leur partie
en 18 qui en fait selon vous intéresse
absolument pas les lecteurs ty pas que
ça n'intéresse pas mais je dis
simplement qu'il faut que tout le monde
se donne la peine de faire les élections
régionales les élections régionales et
le jour où il y aura la présidentielle
en parlant de la présidentielle et à
force de tout mélanger
on entretient dans la population ce
sentiment de confusion totale de partage
des prébendes et tout ça c'est très
malsain
oui alors nous avons justement voulu
aller à la rencontre de ses citoyens aux
demandes de changement après huit ans au
pouvoir le parti libéral p ô a été déchu
par le pis droit et justice en pologne
le parti du très droitier jarreau slavka
chine ce qui nous avons été donc à la
rencontre des habitants d'une petite
ville minière de pologne exactement la
ville de baie atteint sheet blow la
nouvelle premier ministre c'est un
reportage de solesmes nicolas
le
c'est une ville brumeuse de la région
d'auschwitz de cette fameuse pauline b
celle des petites communes ouvrière
catholique de campagne qui se sentent
parfois mise à l'écart de la
retentissante croissance économique du
pays
j'ai j'te c'est aussi la ville natale de
la nouvelle première ministre du parti
droit et justice
béate un shido en a même été maire de
1998 à 2005
c'est auprès de ces régions que le parti
pis a agité la peur de l'immigration et
de l'islam
un discours qui a eu un écho plutôt
nuancé au sein de la population
l'immigration ce n'est pas un problème
ici on accueille les gens ces gens qui
s'enfuit ce ne sont pas eux les fautifs
c'est parce qu'il ya la guerre dans leur
pays mais bien sûr on a peur on a peur
qu'il y ait des terroristes qui se
glisse parmi eux nous les polonais c'est
de ça dont on n'a plus peur lui il a
changé de religion
il n'y a pas longtemps il a voté pour le
parti droit et justice
ce qu'il a dans le coeur mais c'est bien
de changer c'est bien pas brusquement
évidemment il y aller petit à petit mais
il faut que ça change
le changement c'est précisément pour
cela que la plupart des habitants de
cette région ont choisi le parti pis et
croit en ses promesses pour le charbon
qui fournit près de 90% de l'électricité
du pays
car ici tous les habitants où presque en
vivent
il y a un an les mineurs s'était révolté
contre l'ancien gouvernement qui avait
décidé de fermer quatre mines plus assez
rentable en tête de la contestation chez
gorz ici à la une du journal
ce père de famille a passé une semaine à
900 mètres sous la terre alors choisir
pis c'était donc aussi s'affirmer face à
une europe qui impose ses normes
climatiques notamment nous en tant que
mineur on a senti cette entrée dans
l'europe parce qu'on nous a imposé des
restrictions sur les volumes
d'extraction de charbon chaque
gouvernement nous dit que le charbon est
le socle de la pologne
c'est le slogan habituel mais jusqu'à
présent les politiques n'avaient pas
fait grand chose pour nous le charbon
socle de la pologne d'une pologne qui se
sont mis à l'écart par l'europe
le parti droit et justice l'a bien
compris et a promis aux polonais de leur
redonner leur place au sein de l'union
c'est aussi ce que défend le directeur
de la mine d'objets j'te et élus du
parti pis dans la région il y a deux
tendances en pologne
ceux qui sont proches de l'europe et
ceux qui veulent cultiver leur polonité
et le pis a surfé sur cette dernière
tendance sur le fait qu'il faut cultiver
notre identité propre et défendre nos
intérêts nationaux
le discours de campagne du pis c'était
que l'europe défende est surtout les
intérêts allemands et français et qu'il
y a une division entre l'ancienne europe
des pays fondateurs et les nouveaux
venus de l'est
le pis a donc mis en avant le fait que
la pologne est le plus grand pays de la
région et que nous voulons avoir une
voix prépondérante au sein de l'europe
je crois que ç'a eu beaucoup d'impact
dans l'esprit des polonais car nous
sommes tous fiers notre origine de notre
nationalité
et le vote peas n'a pas été circonscrits
aux campagne polonaise la nécessité de
changement s'est fait ressentir jusque
dans les grandes villes comme ici à
cracovie
le parti a renouvelé ses visages à
moderniser son ton et s'était adressé
pendant sa campagne à la jeune
génération
pour ces étudiants traditionnellement de
gauche pis avant tout été un choix
antisystème je vois parmi mes amis même
que
on n'avait pas vraiment des choix
c'était soit is lario et les gens
étaient si fatigué de tpe que beaucoup
des gens ont voté juste pour piste parce
que juste pour faire quelque chose c'est
contre qu'entre après les années de
communisme la pologne souffre donc
peut-être d'un renouvellement de l'offre
politique
pis a su en profiter et se faire élire
sur les frustrations des polonais la
volonté de changement la peur du chômage
et de l'immigration pour une pologne
profondément ancré dans lieu le vote si
ce n'est pas forcément animé par une
volonté de retour aux valeurs
traditionnelles mais c'est peut être un
moyen pour les polonais de réaffirmer un
modèle national de l'europe
edouard martin pologne france même
combat finalement en tout cas on autant
il ya des similitudes
oui mêmes mots les mêmes phrases qui
reviennent c'est le repli sur soi et les
envies de changement surtout le retour
de dix locataires nancy sur toulouse
viennent de renverser la table
ouais envie de renverser la table contre
ce système on l'a bien entendu alors
effectivement ça doit nous interpeller
nous interroger mais en même temps on
voit que la pologne est un pays qui est
en train de connaître les mêmes
mésaventures que la france ya 30 ans 40
ans l'arrière
la désindustrialisation ça aussi c'est
un facteur important parce que dans les
grosses industries où il ya un collectif
de travailleurs eh bien il ya cet esprit
de prise de décision collective
et là c'est un peu le retour à la divine
est assez étonnant sylvie goulard c'est
que on parle quand même d'un pays qui
est autour de 3 4% de croissance depuis
des années et qui a amené plus de leur
nombre de milliards alors je vais je
vais pas vous dire de bêtises avec 4 82
5 milliards d'euros qui vont être
données en ligne entre 2011 et 2020 ol
en mai ce reportage est très révélateur
de plusieurs choses
il ya une volonté de changement en
apparence mais en fait regarder la
question climatique et le charbon n'y a
aucune volonté de changement fait ce
sont des gens qui s'accrochent à un
modèle énergétique qui non seulement est
dépassée pour eux mais qu'ils aient
dépassé pour la planète c'est pas à
bruxelles qu'il ya des individus qui ont
commencé a décrété qu'il fallait
commencer enfin à l'hôtel en termes
d'emploi
non non mais bien qu'il ya aussi le dis
sans qu'on n'y a pas d'alternative c'est
exactement le genre de truc qui nous
plombe depuis des années il ya toujours
des alternatives en politique hockey la
vraie question c'est comment vous qu'on
vous arriver à convaincre des gens qui
reçoivent 4 % de leur produit intérieur
brut par an de l'europe d'arrêter de
cracher à la figure de l'europe parce
que c'est quand même ça c'est dire
qu'ils sont pas dans les postes de
décision alors que leur ancien premier
ministre et président du conseil
européen que pendant cinq ans le
commissaire qui s'occupait des finances
de toute l'union de tout le budget
c'était un polonais et que la pologne
s'en est très bien tiré dans l'ailé
gauche alors tu veux faire que du coup
christian est ce que c'est
cette europe franco-allemande en fait
qui impose un peu ses desiderata à la
pologne à ceux de l'ancien bloc de l'est
tu moi ce qui m'a frappé non non non le
reportage c'est ce que disait sylvie
goulard c'est effectivement ce rejet
d'une europe qui leur impose un
changement de modèle sur lequel ils ont
assis leur économie sait on est allé
dans un bassin minier c'est les gens qui
vivent de 2 qui vise de l'extraction du
charbon et on n'a jamais préparé le
mouvement la transition faim appelle la
transition énergétique de la pologne est
un pays qui tire son électricité à 95%
du charbon ça fait des années qu'on sait
ça fait des années qu'on négocie avec
eux et ça fait des années qu'on ne fait
rien et qui sont toujours avec le
charbon que des négociations se bloquent
entre leurs partenaires aient eu le
paquet climat ça a été un des pays les
plus durs pour accepter le paquet climat
ils n'ont jamais cru ils s'imaginent que
de toute façon des négociations vont
s'effondrer que les négociations de la
coop 21 vont donner quelque chose
les polonais vont ressortir tout le
monde le sait parce qu'ils ne sont pas
du tout contents des contraintes alors
que d'autres pays d'autres grands
acteurs n'auront pas de contrainte et
c'est ça et donc ces gens voient
l'europe comme quelque chose qui leur
impose des choses sans les avoir
préparés où il risque de tout perdre et
ne voit pas du tout la langue a dit à
l'ats moi je vais poser une question
bête c'est la faute à qui cette espèce
de sentiment
est ce qu'on a mal intégré ces pays de
l'est ont arrêté j'ai un problème humain
derrière thoër il ya qu une autre
génération vit un bouleversement complet
un bouleversement des des conditions de
production parce que l'enjeu climatique
devient urgent un bouleversement de
l'organisation politique parce qu'on
fait des élections au niveau national
mais on voit bien que les problèmes que
vous vouliez lutter contre les paradis
fiscaux contre le climat contre les
terroristes les problèmes sont plus
nationaux et vous avez les partis qui
ont le cynisme et c'est absolument
dégoûtantes de dire un des gens ne vous
inquiétez pas on vous assure que rien ne
changera et ils ne font qu'empirer les
choses
et à mon avis c'est aussi parce que des
partis modérés ont beaucoup trop câliner
les électeurs en leur disant vous
inquiétez pas vous n'avez pas à vous
adapter votre identité on va vous
préservez que on se retrouve avec ces
phénomènes
c'est très préoccupant parce que
maintenant vous avez vu combien de fois
le mot on est fiers d'eux on peut être
fier de ce qu'on ait tout en évoluant
hors maman on a un peu l'impression que
la plupart des individus considèrent que
s'il ne s'arc boutent pas sur ce qu'ils
sont le repli que vous avez évoquées eh
bien ils sont menacés dans leur être
alors moi c'est justement edouard martin
en tant qu ancien syndicaliste notamment
à florange quand vous entendez ce que
dit sylvie goulard sur la question de il
faut s'adapter
c était aussi un petit peu le discours
qu'on avait pu à l'époque vous dis enfin
vous n'étiez plus à la hauteur des
enjeux et tout du moins l'acier et des
produits moins cher ailleurs
est ce que le finalement sa différence
que nous on nous annonce du jour au
lendemain que notre site qui joue
rentable mais d'affaires va fermer pas
parce qu'il n'est pas rentable parce
qu'il n'est plus suffisamment rentable
là c'était dans l'intérêt d'un
actionnaire particulier et élections
ordinales la même chose exactement c'est
toujours lakhsmi mittal et d'ailleurs on
voit bien qu'aujourd'hui il est bien
content d'avoir gardé le fils de feu
rouge parce qu'il marque plutôt très
bien
mais pour revenir à ça parce que nous
sommes passés par là même phase en
france et notamment dans ma région
lorraine le charbon calanques à lanton
vert après le charbon et il faut dire
aux travailleurs aux mineurs que c'est
pas l'europe leur impose d'arrêter le
charbon c'est une question effectivement
du climat mais c'est aussi une question
de santé publique les premières victimes
des maladies liées au charbon ce sont
les mineurs et les habitants eux mêmes
mais par contre là où alors je ne sais
pas si je crois pas que ce soit trop de
la faute de l'europe
je rejoins ce que dit sylvie goulard
puisque l'europe est plutôt bien
financièrement la pologne à les
accompagner dans cette transition
sauf que comment se prépare la
transition sur place en ayant des
directeurs qui a un parti pris lé
directeur de la mine en plus il est élu
au désiré et qui dit à ses propres
salariés
ne vous inquiétez pas moi je vais sur
vous devrez a changé alors qui sait
pertinemment bien qu ils obligés de
changer et c'est le ce qui est
dramatique c'est pas tant qu'une minute
où une usine fermée ce qui est
dramatique c'est de se retourner et voir
que c'est le néant il n'y a rien
derrière
donc il faut que y compris
économiquement en prennent un organisme
recensement ils disent aux mineurs on va
peut-être fermer ta mine mais tu auras
toujours un emploi dans une autre mine
dans un autre secteur à côté c'est ça
c'est comme ça qu'on rassure
futur parce que en fait un et un des
mots de tous reportage m'a frappé c'est
peur j'ai peur
les idées des immigrés qui vont arriver
non pas parce que c'est des immigrés
mais parce qu'il peut y avoir des
terroristes et que c'est ma sécurité
j'ai peur pour mon dans le x parce qu'on
veut on veut fermer le charbon et on
offre rien peur peur peur peur on vit
sur les peurs et l'europe ne sait pas
répondre aux peurs n'offrent aucune
réponse hooper alors justement quand on
voit que le drapeau européen a été
enlevé de la salle de conférence de
presse donc du gouvernement polonais est
ce que c'est un peu le début de la fin
et surtout qu'est ce qu'on a à répondre
en fait à 50
matteo renzi dit il faut que l'europe
change sinon ça va faire le lit de
marine le pen encore et encore
qu'est ce qu'elle est qu'elle ait la
possibilité en fait pour l'europe de
lutte et qu'elle comment est-ce qu'on
peut le faire
c'est rigolo non mais que l'europe
doivent changer et encore une fois je
n'ai pas dit que seuls les ouvriers
doivent s'adapter je pense dans notre
société tout le monde doit se remettre
en cause le dû de des patrons les
dirigeants partie jusqu'à tous les
individus on est encore une fois une
génération d'un monde de transition on
n'a pas le choix et ça concerne tout le
monde et c'est seulement si tout le
monde le fait d'ailleurs que ça sera
acceptée par les gens les plus les plus
vulnérables qui ont encore plus de
difficultés et il faut le comprendre à
s'adapter
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire d'abord il
faut réformer l'europe sur un certain
nombre de points
en matière de schengen le problème c'est
la chane kane c'est l'absence de
contrôles aux frontières en matière de
d'intervention extérieure c'est pas que
l'europe 9,1 à l'europe ne fait pas ce
qu'on n'a pas voulu qu'elle fasse on
s'est pas dotée de force d'intervention
extérieure on peut pas utiliser leur
corps ont donc il ya énormément de
chantiers sur lesquels on va pas agir
avec une baguette magique mais où on
peut faire résolument mieux que ce qu'on
a fait avant dernière remarque moi ce
qui me fascine d'ailleurs guy
verhofstadt l'a dit le jour où les
polonais ont enlevé le drapeau la
commission européenne devait suspendre
le paiement des aides à l'appel de la
paf est elle ne l'a pas fait et je
trouve que c'est une responsabilité donc
non mais c'est s'il faut que nous soyons
que nous cessions avec les passes et les
comportements de passager clandestin
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pourquoi tous les
gens votent à l'extrême droite comme
d'ailleurs ils ont voté à l'extrême
gauche en grèce c'est que dans le fond
ils pensent qu'ils vont protester mais
que le système finira pas retenir ils
sont tellement antisystème que dans le
fond ils espèrent qu'il reste de la
place
il se pose jamais la question de savoir
ce qui se passerait vraiment si je
retrouvais tout seul dans la
mondialisation et 100 euros sans
protection des autres européens et donc
c'est ça qu'il faut arrêter tu veux être
dedans tu veux dehors c'est ton choix
mais si tu es dedans tu as des droits et
tu as aussi des devoirs way dernière
question on arrive à la fin de cette
émission j'imagine que vous allez tous
allés voter ce dimanche c'est ce que
sylvie goulard vous serez prêt de vous à
mettre un bulletin les républicains dans
les andes si nécessaire moi je salue le
courage des socialistes ils se sont
retirés je pense que pour l'image
internationale de la france est un geste
majeur
je pense qu'il ya une différence
fondamentale entre des gens dont je ne
partage pas toutes les idées mais que je
respecte avec qui je peux travailler et
des individus qui donne de la france
l'image de haine et de violence que
madame le pen a donné face à madame
merkel au parlement européen c'est à
dire un flot d'insultés et de xénophobie
et de haine en plus c'est un clan
familial est en train de mettre la
france sous coupe réglée dans je n'ai
pas d'états d'âme je voterai pour tous
les modérés qui pourront lui faire
barrage et vous et de la marfin vous
allez soutenir jean-pierre masseret
entière mais effectivement j'aurais aimé
que sylvie goulard qui salue ceux qui se
sont désistés pour son parti au fond
tout cas sans alliance condamne de la
même manière régnier qui lui se
maintient et qui condamne peut-être les
incriminant le poids hier soir où
monsieur nicolas sarkozy voyez trouve
alors il nous explique y compris les
républicains et ses alliés que le front
national est un parti dangereux qui va
mettre le pays au chaos et je partage
assez et en même temps leur présentant
hier soir annonce qu' il n'est pas
immoral de voter front national
cherchez l'erreur ouais christian
cheminement quand vous regardez ça
depuis bruxelles vous avez pas vraiment
envie d'entrer en france n'ont pas
spécialement bon merci à tout ça il y
aurait qu en belgique que c'est
vachement bien
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat nous avoir un petit peu éclairé
sur cette question la semaine prochaine
vous avez rendez vous avec ahmed tazir à
très bientôt sur les chaînes
parlementaires